in other news this morning there is one
week left to voice your opinion on an
important effort here in the community
it is the one october memorial bianca
holmen live this morning on the south
end of the las vegas strip with the
details on this giant good morning
hey good morning john so we're near las
vegas boulevard and tropicana you can
see now there is a sign here
at the route 91 harvest festival site
detailing efforts to build a permanent
one october memorial and now there is
time to share your thoughts on elements
the memorial
should include so far 3505
people have taken the survey the survey
was created by the one october memorial
advisory committee
it's a group about seven people who want
the community input for a permanent one
october memorial
structure to remember the victims the
survivors and heroes that left their
mark here
in las vegas the first survey
demonstrated that a clear majority 66
percent believe it was extremely or very
important to have the memorial
be built at the route 91 harvest
festival site so mgm resorts
international they donated
two acres on the northeast corner on the
car of the concert site adjacent to the
church for
the memorial we actually spoke with
menda smith her sister nessa tonks was
one of the 58 victims killed at the
festival
smith says this memorial is a major
milestone in the journey
of healing not only was our city
impacted but it went so much further and
the love and the support with the
prayers with the
um donations of all sorts i think that
anyone who had any kind of emotion with
this should have a say in this
i i kind of like to say if you felt
anything from october 1 you should
definitely
take the survey
yeah so we were talking and she said you
know if you're a person who gave blood
or know a survivor
they want your ideas so again the
educational components the
structure the artistic the format of it
all they want your details and input
and of course be be sure to check your
text messages and your email they've
sent out that link several times and
we've also tweeted it out
so again we have shared this information
on our website on our social media
channels
again that survey it wraps up in about a
week so there's still time to voice your
opinion
bianca holmen 8 news now